ah
a
todos los días encontramos cosas que nos
gustan y con los que queremos cambiar
las primeras obviamente nos dan alegría
y las segundas alimentan nuestro deseo
profundo por quieren cambiar el huerto
requiere de riesgos de enfrentar el
miedo al fracaso de nada en contra de la
corriente y de creer en lo imposible e
incluso en momentos de mayor velocidad
pensamos esas personas en ello para
comenzar me gustaría hacerte una
pregunta qué crees que hacer
fisioterapeuta viendo un momento y
guardar la respuesta pues esta misma
pregunta si la idea un par de amigos yo
quería saber qué pensaban ellos acerca
de lo que hace nuestra profesión y esto
fue lo que ellos respondieron que somos
más artistas que tratamos lesiones
musculares encajamos huesos que
rehabilitamos accidentes que enderezamos
personas cuando están torcidas y que
hacemos que sobran durante las terapias
algo que de cierta manera es verdad
estas son algunas de las opiniones y
después de hacer este ejercicio la
refuerza que en más gravoso fue la de mi
papá
su respuesta fue de que nosotros los
fisioterapeutas hacemos que los dolores
no sean tan tensos generamos una mejor
recuperación del paciente y los
acompañados para que su tratamiento sea
mucho mejor nosotros los ayudamos a
quienes puedan tener una mejor calidad
de vida y aunque si hacemos todo lo
anterior hay muchísimo más de tal un
fisioterapeuta nosotros acompañamos
desde incontinencias urinarias dolores
crónicos personas con discapacidad y
hasta enfermedades pulmonares
con la pandemia muchos personas de
cuenta de lo importante que es hacer
transformación digital en el área de la
salud las ventajas que se obtienen son
infinitas comenzando por la
accesibilidad a los servicios de salud
un aumento en el nivel de satisfacción
una reducción de en cuánto tiempo es en
casa un paciente para llegar al centro
de salud y muchísimas cosas más
durante esta pandemia tenemos la
oportunidad de ayudar a más de 700
personas a recuperar de las escuelas del
color web ayudamos a que nuestros
pacientes pudieran respirar sin sentir
fatiga a realizar actividades del día a
día del dolor y sin cansancio les
brindamos acompañamientos y durante su
proceso de recuperación los educamos y
les brindamos algunos ejercicios para
hacer caso
tratamos del dolor físico con las
dificultades respiratorias durante este
tiempo también nos convertimos en una
especie de consejeros y amigos
escuchamos sus historias personales les
acompañamos en todo momento y aunque
parezca increíble todo esto lo logramos
a través de una vida y agua
y la de la fisioterapia digital
acortamos barreras y logramos acercarnos
a nuestros pacientes reducir los costos
en tratamientos innecesarios y evitamos
que la saturación del sistema de salud
sea mucho mayor haciendo mucho más
eficiente el accedió a la rehabilitación
brindando una mejor calidad en la
atención y es aquí donde quiero contarte
un poco acerca de mi historia yo soy
fisioterapeuta y por mucho tiempo viví
frustrado con un sistema donde creemos
que la salud es un privilegio y no un
derecho también ejemplo las personas
viven con dolor demora en varias semanas
para tener una primera cita con un
fisioterapeuta y viajan largas horas de
ser su pueblo para llegar al centro de
salud sentía un deber para cambiar un
poco de este sistema pero no sabía cómo
y fue allí donde conocí a juan quien es
desarrollador de software ingeniero y
juntos decidimos crear algo donde
pudiéramos mezclar la tecnología con la
fisioterapia
para crear algo que impactará la salud
de nuestro país y de toda latinoamérica
y es allí donde nace gente nosotros
hacemos la fisioterapia accesible para
todos a través de una plataforma que le
permite al fisioterapeuta dar atención a
esos pacientes de forma remota oa
distancia millones de pacientes en el
mundo se han dado cuenta de los grandes
beneficios de la telemedicina incluyendo
la accesibilidad a los servicios aumentó
el nivel de satisfacción en menos horas
en el tráfico para llegar a un hospital
entre muchísimas cosas más que darte
tres consejos que han marcado mi vida
como emprendedora en el área de la salud
primero es en momentos de frustración e
inconformidad donde puedes crear las
ideas más increíbles todos tenemos las
herramientas necesarias para hacer el
mundo un lugar mucho mejor de lo que
encontramos desde cualquier área del
conocimiento
segundo enfócate siempre en las personas
con los esos dolores y sus necesidades
la empatía es la base para crear
tecnologías centradas en las personas
su proyecto es mucho más que una idea
maravillosa debes tener un propósito y
no sólo los que no se me r
tercero escoria movimiento sociedad es
como un matrimonio un gran compromiso
del cual debes esforzarte para que
realmente funcione intenta encontrar a
alguien que quiera remar en la misma
dirección y comparta su misma visión
seguramente llegarán muy lejos cuando la
innovación se trata creemos que es para
personas creativas fuertes y esas que
son inmunes al fracaso y que están
programados para que ser rebeldes
revolucionarios e incluso impermeables
al rechazo pero esta charla es para ti
para ti que eres escritor cantante
profesor o doctor las personas que
quieren resolver todos los problemas
interesantes del mundo para personas que
están en el camino de convertirse en
fisioterapeutas médicos pintores o
líderes personas como nosotros no
importa el camino que quieras tomar
intenta buscar eso que te apasiona y no
te conformes con hacer las cosas como
siempre te han enseñado cuestiona todo
lo que vas a aprender hay muchos
procesos que están mandado de recoger y
tu tarea es encontrar ideas para
mejorarlos y hacerlos mucho más
eficientes hoy en día no necesitas
títulos masters certificados o un súper
traje elegante no solamente servido de
pasión sino que se vive de esfuerzo y de
ganas de riesgos de tomar decisiones que
signifiquen todo o nada y sobre todo la
decisión de creer en eso que tienes en
tu corazón y lo te rindas a pesar de las
dificultades
en un mundo donde todo parece complicado
debemos inspirar a hacer las cosas
referente más sencillas más simples y
mucho más accesibles a las personas y
volviendo a la pregunta del inicio si
esta persona podría ser yo y la
respuesta es sí
tú y yo podemos hacer que el mundo sea
un lugar mucho mejor de lo que lo hemos
encontrado